les pertes d'emplois font partie du
quotidien et emmanuel l'écuyer dans les
dernières années avec la chute des prix
du pétrole
il a dû licencier plus de 90% de ses
employés c'était la seule façon de
garder son entreprise manufacturière à
flot c'est important de protéger et
protéger partout au canada non seulement
au québec ou en ontario mais partout et
c'est là où le bât blesse selon de
nombreux albertains
car si justin trudeau et son ancien
conseiller gerald bottes ont répété
l'importance de protéger les 9000
emplois de snc lavalin
les libéraux ont montré moins
d'empressement et des l'alberta depuis
quatre ans croit emmanuel écuyer
spécialement qu'on a perdu deux mondes
sont pas au courant encore comment grave
que l'association fédérale tu as beau
avoir investi quatre milliards et demi
de dollars pour l'achat du pipeline
trans l'antenne c'était trop peu trop
tard 17 autres travailleurs pour
l'instant ça n'a rien donné
explique-t-il il n'y a toujours rien
construit dans cette station de radio de
calgary l'ancien leader politique de
droite danielle smith maintenant
animatrice en temps la colère des
albertains
les gens ici semble que justin trudeau
cherche à favoriser le québec dit elle
il n'aime pas ça elle ne pense pas par
contre que le scandale va renforcer les
sentiments anti québécois françois
legault
selon elle les déclarations de françois
legault sur le pétrole sale de l'alberta
au moment où sa province recevait de
l'argent de la péréquation ont été bien
plus mal accueillie elle croit que les
albertains en veulent surtout aux
libéraux pour le scandale snc-lavalin
cette commentatrice politique qui écrit
pour des magazines comme hecklen
reconnaît qu'il y ait un risque de
dérapage
malgré tout elle croit que les
travailleurs albertains sont capables de
faire la part des choses car ils ont
beaucoup en commun avec les travailleurs
québécois lors des dernières élections
fédérales les libéraux avaient réussi à
remporter quatre sièges en alberta
ça peut sembler peu mais c'était
considéré en 2015 comme une percée or
aujourd'hui avec la grogne qui
continuent de monter contre le
gouvernement trudeau
plusieurs analystes politiques voit mal
comment les libéraux pourraient garder
ne serait ce qu'un seul siège en alberta
ici l'heure incertain radio canada
calgary